yo what is up everybody it is procedure
man Luigi here with another Borderlands
EP sequel legendary guide today the
video is about the quasar it is a hate
Hyperion legendary grenade mod it's red
text reads e equals MC to the OMG / WTF
power it is a singularity grenade mod
that also does shock damage a good
amount of shock damage and it can be
acquired from farming Felicity or from
getting a vending machine or chests as
other Legendary's can so it is a pretty
good grenade I do I found that it really
actually is good for killing a mah just
kind of general mobs
that you face like just in general
bandits and scabs and kind of foot
soldiers against bosses I haven't used
it too much I can like raid bosses and
stuff but because it is a singularity
that pulls them in and also does shock
damage it really it takes out the
shields of anybody super quick and a lot
of times it will even get the confirming
kill you can see the one I have is a 48
that means it can be better up to two
levels when you level 50 so we can do
even better
so I think it is a really good grenade
that if you did it you should definitely
hold on to it I think out of most of the
grenades in terms of just normal
practicality use it has been one of my
favorites it now I see I have the sticky
longbow which I prefix which I think
might be one of the best ones since I
can throw it it teleports wherever I
throw it and then makes a singularity
there which is very useful versus a lob
rubber one that will bounce around until
it finds an enemy so and because it's a
singularity singularity grenade I can
throw it to where I want perfectly and
then the enemies we pulled there say if
I want to just get past and don't need
to kill them I'll move them out of the
way so I can continue on to my goal so
I'm going to be showing you where to get
it and kind of some gameplay of it so I
hope you enjoy the video all right so
first thing you're gonna want to do is
head to the Titan robot production plant
you see I'm here right at the start
there are six vending machines and four
to five chests on this run four
I mean Felicity so I would suggest
always heading up those since you can
also sell your Luanne you have a good
chance of getting the legendaries now
you're going to want after you hit up a
vending machines you're just going to
want to you can go straight through the
pet the areas or you can run to the side
running to the side you'll do a little
more avoidance of the enemies but
running straight you'll be good too so
you're just going to want to run
straight through the map as far as you
can I would say go under this bridge
walkway you can it's a very
straightforward easy path and you'll
dodge a lot of enemies so keep going you
can kind of run past these guys I show
them a little bit and then make a left
here you're gonna see the three more of
the vending machines and oh and let me
say that it's actually five to six
chests I forgot there's another chest
right here uh four on this run now after
this area you're gonna run into Felicity
who is a constructor boss that you do
fight in the main storyline but is a
raid boss as well I would suggest using
corrosive weapons I'm Nisha and I have
some Maggie's however I picked up some
Karoshi crochet corrosive pistols later
and it killed felicity debt at least had
like ten times fast I would say I was
able to kill Felicity in three mags of
some Vlad off TMP krause pistols so if
you have a good corrosive weapon
definitely use it on Felicity
I would say stay behind her and watch
out for her turning on you while she has
her constructor shield up since if you
shoot that shield where a guard when it
guards her critical spot it will bounce
bull's back at you and you can down
yourself there's a lot of stuff to get
up if you down herself on her like
turrets and she spawns a lot of things
so be on the lookout for that now you
see she just kind of spews out her drops
if she does not drop the quasar first
then she's not going to drop the quasar
so if you just want to get into it fast
then does if she doesn't drop it safe
quick go but I wasn't just hitting up
these chests in the room just right
behind her since you can get Legendary's
one run of this I found two legendaries
so one out of the four chests two of
them had Legendary's so I'd say
definitely check them alright now we're
gonna get into a little bit a play of
the quasar you can see it pulling and it
enemy's doing some really serious damage
if I was holding a Marx's weapon it'd be
really good for leech health gaining
health back and so it a lot harder to
down yourself to get down by enemies you
can see it's really I'm not shooting
that much I'm shooting a few guys yes
especially when I don't feel the grenade
but even against these armor guys it
pulls them and it shocks them a Chuck's
the guy inside it really does a lot of
work ie
I like the grenade a lot if you're gonna
be using it really for any any person
especially people with higher elemental
chance and elemental damage especially
the elemental damage it's pretty great
also you make maybe you saw at the end
of that segment of killing guys if you
hit someone with your grenade like since
I've singularity if I just throw it at
them it will create a singularity in the
air and shock people from that I think
that's the the best part of this grenade
is a pretty cool animation it pulls up
all the other effects that are on the
ground and it does make a singularity
like a quasar own by the way if you
don't know quasar is a giant huge body
in space of heat and energy and kind of
like a massive massive black hole so
$0.02 not exactly like that but it says
yet somehow you get an idea of what it's
like so that's kind of it for me I hope
you've enjoyed this video how to get the
quasar and how it it is it is a really
good grenade I do suggest using it a lot
I hope you still stick around on my
channel I'm going to be putting up a lot
more Borderlands DP sequel legendary
guys and I have put up a lot more legend
I have put up a few legendary guys
before this video so check them out and
I will just be putting up a bunch of
Beurling stuff so if you like
Borderlands that make sure you keep an
eye on my channel that's it for the
video hope you guys have enjoyed and
I'll see you all next time atlas